♪ ♪
>> Shannon: DE DAY, THE SIXTH
OF JUNE.
TODAY IS THE 74TH ANNIVERSARY OF
THAT DAY, CONSIDERED THE TURNING
POINT IN WORLD WAR II.
NATIONAL SECURITY CORRESPONDENT
JENNIFER GRIFFIN SHOWS US HOW
IT'S BEING REMEMBERED.
>> YOUR TASK WILL NOT BE AN EASY
ONE.
YOUR ENEMY IS WELL-TRAINED,
WELL-EQUIPPED, AND BATTLE
HARDENED.
HE WILL FIGHT SAVAGELY.
WE WILL ACCEPT NOTHING LESS THAN
FULL VICTORY.
>> WITH THOSE WORDS,
GENERAL DWIGHT D. EISENHOWER
LAUNCH THE D-DAY INVASION
SENDING MORE THAN 156,000 ALLIED
TROOPS TO FRANCE TO FREE
TROOPS TO FRANCE TO FREE EUROPE
FROM NAZI GERMANY'S GRIP.
MANY DIED ON THE BEACHES OF
NORMANDY.
JUNE 6, 1944.
VISITORS MARK THE ANNIVERSARY OF
THE AMERICAN MILITARY CEMETERY
ABOVE THE BEACHES.
SOME WHO SURVIVED ATTENDED A
CEREMONY WREATH LAYING AT THE
WORLD WAR II MEMORIAL IN
WASHINGTON, D.C.
>>
ON D-DAY.
HE FOUGHT IN THE BATTLE OF THE
BULGE AND HELPED LIBERATE
DACHAU.
>> JOINED BY A MAN DRAFTED AS HE
LEFT HIGH SCHOOL.
>> HE LANDED AT OMAHA BEACH ON
D-DAY PLUS ONE.
>> HAND-TO-HAND BATTLE.
>> LINCOLN WAS JUST OVER 19,
MANNED THE ARTILLERY AND ENTERED
GOLD BEACH WITH BRITISH FORCES.
>> IT WAS IMPORTANT TO GET A
FOOTHOLD.
FROM THEN ON, IT WAS A MATTER OF
WHERE DO WE GO NEXT?
>> AT OUR ROSE GARDEN CEREMONY,
SIGNING LEGISLATION TO HELP ALL
VETERANS, PRESIDENT TRUMP
REMEMBERED THE GREATEST